die heute show am ende einer und das
muss man so sagen am ende einer
furchtbaren woche liebe zuschauer der
anschlag von halle wirklich ein horror
den man tatsächlich erstmal sacken
lassen sollte um sich in ruhe zu
überlegen was zu tun wäre gegen
judenhass und rechten terror einen sehr
konkreten vorschlag hätte ich allerdings
direkt mal wie wär's denn wenn man nach
solchen anschlägen wie am mittwoch
einfach mal für drei vier fünf tage das
internet komplett ab stellt komplett ja
so eine art ungesunde art digitales
schweige woche was uns da erspart bliebe
nehmen wir ja irgendeinen beliebigen
tweet der letzten tage wirklich
irgendein zum beispiel zum beispiel
meine damen und herren
da heißt es was sind das nur für
menschen die anderen menschen so etwas
antun ist inhaltlich völlig richtig
stimmt alles wenn das allerdings jemand
twitter der in bezug aufs dritte reich
eine zitat erinnerungs politische wende
um 180 grad fordert dann hat dieser
jemand eine perfekte gelegenheit
verpasst einfach mal die fresse zu
halten ja
ja
und wo wir dabei sind das gilt übrigens
auch für betroffene als pos von hitler
vogelschuss opas mit hunde krawatte
einfach fresse kuck mal wer hier weiß
nicht mal wie man seinen namen schreibt
[Applaus]
einfach so
mehr dazu demnächst jetzt liebe
zuschauer reden wir über donald trump
dessen präsidentschaft da sind wir uns
einig in die gefährlichste phase
eintritt donalds nerven liegen blank
deswegen amtsenthebungsverfahren so und
um davon mal ein bisschen abzulenken
zieht er seine truppen die us-truppen
aus nordsyrien ab ja seine entscheidung
und erdogan so cool ich bin einmal da
alle lassen jetzt die kunden im stich
ohne die wir den ersten besiegt hätten
aber natürlich hat der donald für sowas
immer gute gründe die kurden kämpfen um
ihr land und wie jemand in einem sehr
eindrucksvollen artikel geschrieben hat
haben sie uns auch nicht im zweiten
weltkrieg geholfen
wir haben uns zum beispiel nicht in der
normandie geholfen
hoffentlich sagt ihm keiner dass wir
deutschen damals in der normandie auch
nicht geholfen haben
egal im abends enthebung verfahren gegen
trump wird jetzt jedenfalls richtig eng
zwei whistleblower wollen aussagen der
vorwurf lautet amtsmissbrauch und da
geht es um ein bestimmtes telefonat von
donald trump mit der ukraine im kern
darin hat er deren präsidenten
aufgefordert schmutz über seinen rivalen
joe biden und dessen sohn zu sammeln
bis heute gibt es zwar 0 beweise dass
die beiden es irgendwas kriminelles
gemacht werden aber hauptsache mit dreck
werfen
manchmal denke ich wirklich wenn ich dem
so zuhöre der schwarm selber hört sich
gar nicht zu
ja in wirklichkeit gibt es genau einen
menschen enthält tatsächlich haben das
genie und sein anwalt rudy giuliani ja
schon öffentlich zugegeben dass sie die
ukraine zur wahlkampfhilfe aufgefordert
haben öffentlich zugegeben
so nach dem motto wenn ich was zu je
bekannter wurde illegal seien
trump denkt wirklich r steht über dem
gesetz seine regierung verweigert stumpf
jede zusammenarbeit mit dem kongress
gibt es überhaupt nicht zuletzt hat sich
ihm wenn man darüber nachdenkt
eigentlich nur noch einmal erfolgreich
widersetzt und zwar der finnische
präsident ab sofort mein persönlicher
held wegen dieser szene hier touch ding
rein und dann diese fantastische
handbewegung nochmal die zeiten mitte
januar sie
[Applaus]
ja
hashtag miete wenn wenn überhaupt muss
trump sich selber wegen korruption
anzeigen und nicht die beiden er möchte
den nächsten g 7 gipfel in einem seiner
hotels in florida stattfinden lassen das
ist korruption stört auch kein der
donald ist jedenfalls gerade auf 180 es
stinkt wütend weil er sagt ein am 10
ein amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen den
größten präsidenten der je gelebt hat
das gibt's doch gar nicht und seinen
wilden ungebändigten zorn kriegen
wirklich alle ab sogar parteifreunde der
einflussreiche republikanische senator
romney allerdings nennt trumps
unverschämte und beispiellose anfrage
nach ermittlungen gegen joe biden falsch
und katastrophal
trump twitter zurück mitt romney wusste
nie wie man gewinnt er ist ein
aufgeblasener arsch aufgeblasener
schulträger zu fall genau unter dem
namen hat melania ihren mann auf dem
handy gespeichert aufgeblasen hast ja
dagegen
ja
zugegeben wahrscheinlich wird das
amtsenthebungsverfahren am ende im senat
scheitern sagen alle
andererseits darf man die demokratie
auch nicht kampflos aufgeben es ist
wirklich spannend was werden die
geschichtsbücher am ende über donald
schon sagen wahrscheinlich dass er der
eine präsident war der seine interviews
rätselhafte weise am liebsten direkt
neben einem hubschrauber gibt mit ihr
redet keiner
twittern braucht wirklich hilfe holt
weiterhin braucht hilfe wie jetzt
herauskam hat trump in einem meeting mit
beratern neue vorschläge für die
sicherung der mexikanischen grenze
gemacht seine idee und das ist jetzt
ganz ausdrücklich kein geld von uns
seine idee sein vorschlag man soll doch
entlang der mauer zu mexiko einen
wassergraben bauen mit schlangen und
alligatoren trennen ich hätte so gern
die gesichter seiner berater gesehen ist
großartig oder großartig und das war
noch nicht alles
später schlug er vor flüchtlinge in die
beine zu schießen um sie zu verlangsamen
man sagt ihm das ist auch nicht erlaubt
voll ungerecht da war dort noch so viele
andere fiese mexikaner abwehr ideen im
köcher wenn man ihn lässt demnächst sind
in der grenzmauer wohl sehr viele türen
aber wenn dann illegaler mexicana
dadurch geht der krieg darüber was ab
und wenn er trotzdem weiter läuft
erschreckt dass ich furchtbar denn trump
hat überall gut angelegt war und dann
kommt der graben aber ohne alligatoren
wegen tierschutz durfte die nicht dafür
hat man aber 30 millionen
meerschweinchen gekauft und zwar nicht
irgendwelche sondern aus bologna mehr
schwanken die taktiken
kreativ
das muss man ihm lassen kreativ es
wirklich die entscheidende frage was ist
bei donald trump noch strategie und was
ist schlicht galoppieren irrsinn erfüllt
nämlich nicht nur krieg gegen demokraten
medien und mexikaner
jetzt hatte auch noch beef mit der
achtung energiesparlampe wirklich jetzt
er hasst energiesparlampen
eine zollunion
hitze
deshalb und ich dachte er wäre als baby
in ein fass mit selbstbräuner gefallen
wir schalten live nach washington zu
tina hausten
ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ich weiß selber wie
ich aussehe oliver das zdf team dreht
mit der energiesparlampe vielen dank
auch ja aber egal
hier ist was passiert das hätte nie
passieren dürfen
der präsident hat auf dem klo zwischen
alten clay boys die amerikanische
verfassung gefunden und gelesen
ja sie haben richtig gehört donald trump
hat was gelesen also nur bis artikel 2
dann ist er ein gepennt aber
ausgerechnet den hat er sich gemerkt
nichts davon steht in artikel 2 nichts
seine berater versuchen seit tagen ihm
zu erklären dass danach noch ganz ganz
ganz ganz ganz viele artikel kommen mit
ganz vielen buchstaben wo drinsteht wie
die macht des präsidenten kontrolliert
wird ja aber erklären sie das mal einem
verzogenen adhs kind im körper eines
dementen grabl opas ja
chris und das klingt ein bisschen
je näher das klingt jetzt so ein
bisschen als leere trump endgültig auf
dem weg zum autokraten ja nein also wie
war ich kann hier nicht so offen
sprechen
er trump lässt neuerdings alle halbe
stunde alligatoren auf uns fake news los
ja und der wahnsinn hat leider methode
das ganze theater macht er ja nur weil
die beiden in manchen umfragen vor ihm
liegt deswegen nennt er ihn nur noch
roger und stellt sich vor wie der mit
dem präsidenten von china verhandeln
würde sich nichts sehnlicher als den
schläfrigen so können sie sich die
beiden in einem raum vorstellen hier und
hier das schläfrige giorgio
unterschreibt einfach hier
es ist wirklich so kindergarten ja alle
seine gegner kriegen jetzt fiese
spitznamen sleepy joe biden crockett
hillary und angela merkel hinter nur
noch mit angie ja sie wissen schon hier
wegen dieser einen szene bei ihrem
letzten gespräch wo sie ihnen zweimal
doch das muss man so hart sagen
mimisch beleidigt hat
bei den german
ein gesicht ein gesicht wie eine
kriegserklärung ja das war zu hart zu
hart er ist so stolz auf seine deutschen
wurzeln
sein großvater frederik er stammt ja aus
der pfalz aus einem der schönsten
deutschen in schutzgebiete ja da lacht
man nicht wieder hin und wird dafür
jetzt glauben sie wird es noch eng für
tram mit der amtsenthebung schlimme wort
nicht
donald trump ist im moment wie bison
angeschossene wildsau ja also ich sagen
oliver der geht hier niemals freiwillig
raus den müssen sie raus cern und
deshalb hat er sich auch angeblich extra
aus japan eine 90 unity chef geholt
china natürlich jeder aus dem hause an
klickt hier für weitere heute schon
videos und klickt moment
und klickt hier um den channel zu
abonnieren
[Musik]